à tous alors on est dans un monde qui
change très vite et aujourd'hui ce dont
on entend très souvent parler c'est de
l'homme bionique de l'homme augmenté des
membres artificiels
je vais aller un petit peu en contrepied
de tout ça et je vais vous parler de
prothèses de membres inférieurs aux
thèses membres à faire ailleurs malgré
tout ça reste un membre artificiel et je
vais vous présenter ces aspects sous
roche biomécanique et également je vous
parlais de l'appareillage qui est un
beau métier qui consiste à adapter un
système artificiel à une personne bien
particulière pour remplacer l'anatomie
qu'elle a perdu qu avant de vous parler
de deux mécaniques je voudrais juste
avoir quelques mots sur le handicap le
handicap c'est une notion qui est ex la
comprend de mieux en mieux aujourd'hui
et le handicap on peut le définir sous
trois aspects ou en tout cas avoir trois
volets à la notion de handicap
la première chose la plus importante
c'est le projet de vie d'une personne
deuxième chose c'est que cette personne
c'est un individu il est unique
avoir des différences entre hop là je
peux avoir une influence sur ce handicap
et ce handicap il va avoir des effets
qui vont être plus ou moins importants
en fonction de l'environnement dans
laquelle la personne en situation de
handicap se trouve la société dans
laquelle évolue la société qui va
limiter les barrières ou qui va essayer
de limiter son handicap ou qui au
contraire ne va pas faire grand chose
pour elle une société qui va décider de
prendre en charge ce handicap un niveau
plus ou moins élevé que le handicap qui
est à la base une limitation de son
interaction avec son environnement va se
répercuter sur l'ensemble de ces trois
volets ou moi je travaille dans un
laboratoire de biomécanique et du coup
la biomécanique je vous en parler
maintenant
c'est une des disciplines qui nous
permet de s'intéresser un petit peu à
ces trois volets s'intéresser au projet
de vie d'une personne aux activités
qu'elles réalisent s'intéresser aux
spécificités individuelles de la
personne à qui on a affaire et
s'intéresser ou
peut-être pas directement la société
mais en tout cas à l'environnement dans
lesquelles ces personnes évoluent alors
la biomécanique c'est une discipline
sciences de l'ingénieur mais qui se
trouve à la frontière avec les sciences
du vivant alors la biomécanique ça
s'intéressent à énormément de deux
champs différence et c'est également et
plus dans mon cas un outil qui nous
permet de s'intéresser à la locomotion
la locomotion ça peut sembler
extrêmement banal mais au final c'est
une activité qui est extrêmement
complexe de par le fait que notre
appareil locomoteur est extrêmement
complexe et constitue une multi os
différentes articulations ses
articulations vont être contrôlés par
une multitude de mu en rose vous avez
quelques musset un schéma qui représente
l'action des muscs on dit mono
articulaires donc des muscles août
l'articulation en avoir des agonistes et
des antagonistes et les articulations
vont dépendre de de la bataille entre
ces deux murs a également d'autres
muscles qu'on appelle dit articulaires
qui sont là on violait donc contrôler le
mouvement de deux articulations
successives a deux qui sont extrêmement
importants au niveau de la cuisse et un
qui est également très important au
niveau du mollet qui va contrôler à la
fois le mouvement du pied et de la
cheville mais en même temps le mouvement
du genou dans le cas d'une amputation
donc une personne va perdre une partie
de son membres inférieurs si cette
amputation a lieu au dessus du genou va
conserver ou en tout cas le chirurgien
va essayer de conserver au maximum les
muscles mono articulaires mais par
contre au niveau des muscles qui était
bien articulaires le chirurgien va
remanier le membre résiduelles futur et
entre ses muscles bien articulaires et
cette fois ci ses muscles ne vont avoir
une action plus que sur la hanche
résiduelle de la personne et après le
métier de de leur taux prothésiste ça va
être de concevoir une interface entre le
membre résiduelle de la personne qui a
été amputée
on va appeler une en voiture et le
fabricant de dispositifs prothétique son
objectif ça va être de remplacer la
partie de l'appareil locomoteur qui est
perdu par des dispositifs artificielle
au niveau du genou on va assembler des
articulations avec des actionnaires qui
peuvent être hydraulique au niveau du
pied on a tellement de muscle tellement
d'eau tellement de ligaments tellement
de temps donc aujourd'hui la solution la
plus efficace et la plus performante
c'est de remplacer cet ensemble de dos
et de solide par un seul système mais
qui lui va être déformable et du pouce
formation va lui permettre de en
magazines et de l'énergie et de la
restituer alors en biomécanique on
dispose d'outils extrêmement performant
grâce à ce monde qui évolue et donc on
utilise les techniques qu'on peut
aujourd'hui voir dans l'animation ou
dans le cinéma qui consiste à mesurer le
mouvement humain donc c'est une à vienne
dit c'est une très vieille discipline
mais qui aujourd'hui est complètement
informatique
on va pouvoir mesurer en 3d le mouvement
est terminé les vitesses des
accélérations et en même temps couple et
ses analyses la mesure de l'action
mécanique exercé à l'homme sur son
environnement et notamment sur le sol du
coup quand on conçoit un composant
prothétique aujourd'hui ce qu'on cherche
à faire c'est à quantifier le mouvement
d'une personnes asymptomatiques
quantifier le mouvement d'une personne
qui est appareillée identifier les
limites et les compensations que ses
composants vont introduire que soit en
s'intéressant à des chaînes de solides
rigide ou à des systèmes qui vont être
des formats parallèle de ces analyses
qu'on peut faire sur une personne qui
est appareillé ce qu'on cherche à faire
c'est à développer des maquettes qu'elle
soit expérimentale ou numérique qui vont
dans un premier temps nous aider à
comprendre comment peut fonctionner un
membre artificiel
comment cet ensemble mécanique peut nous
aider à marcher
et dans un deuxième temps en exploitant
ses maquettes numériques ce qu'on
cherche à faire c'est optimiser la
réponse de ces systèmes dans deux
objectifs par exemple on peut essayer
d'optimiser un composants existants pour
d'autres activités de la vie quotidienne
donc faire courir des personnes qui
jusqu'à présent ne pouvait à ou alors
cherché à optimiser ses composants non
pas pour un jeune sportif mais pour des
personnes qui peuvent être vieillissante
et présenter d'autres pathologies
aujourd'hui au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle les prothèses de membres
inférieurs il ya un gold standard qui
est utilisé et jour par des personnes
qui sont appareillés et il va se
constituer de haut niveau du genou a
cédé deux systèmes qui sont pilotés par
des microprocesseurs
du coup au sein même de la prothèse vous
avez une multitude de capteurs qui vont
permettre d'estimer de récupérer de
l'information et d'estimer la situation
dans laquelle on se trouve
les informations vont être rapatriés
vers un microcontrôleur qui va embarquer
différents algorithmes et qui va venir
par l'intermédiaire de petits
actionnaires modifier la réponse
mécanique d'un système typiquement on va
venir piloter des vannes hydraulique
pour autoriser un freinage plus ou moins
importants en fonction d'eux est ce que
la personne descendre l'escalier est ce
qu'elle est en train de marcher est-ce
qu'elle marche à une vitesse importante
ou une vitesse réduite à s'asseoir aidée
à descendre des pentes les pieds
prothétique c'est ce dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure ce sont des
hommes qui sont des fort mal en
matériaux composites pour gagner en
rigidité en légèreté et qui vont
permettre à la personne de se déplacer
sur les différents environnements
urbains et système là aujourd'hui on le
sait ils ont énormément apporté aux
personnes qui sont amputés de nos jours
il aura améliorer la qualité de vie et
améliorer leur sécurité
typiquement les genoux avec des
microprocesseurs si vous trébuchez la
prothèse va s'en apercevoir
et plutôt que de vous laisser
complètement tombée elle va vous freinez
et empêcher que vous que vous tombiez
sur le sol en revanche au niveau de 2 et
composants actuels et y persistent des
difficultés et les personnes quand on
les fait parler elles vont vous dire
qu'elles ont des difficultés non pas sur
un terrain bien
la bien horizontale elles vont vous dire
que les difficultés elles apparaissent
quand elle évolue à l'extérieur de leur
maison partie de ces difficultés vont
provenir d'un manque d'adaptation du
pied et de la cheville
on imagine bien qu'un pied qui a une
rigidité fixe qui va être fixes pendant
la phase aussi lente va faire que votre
orteils va avoir du mal à se dégager du
sol et quand vous allez monter une pente
bâti pique ça va augmenter votre il le
risque que vos orteils touche le sol et
entraîné la chute
vous descendez une pente et que votre
pied à une raideur qui est prévu pour de
la marche à plat en décembre de pente
la raideur sera trop élevé votre pied y
aura trop tard à plat ce qui va faire
que vous allez être plus longtemps sur
le coin du talon et de forcément vous
allez augmenter votre risque de glissade
à certaines situations comme la descente
d'escalier ou là la rigidité elle est
prévue pour marcher sur du plat nous
avec nos muscles on est capable de
modifier en permanence la raideur
équivalente de l'autre cheville personne
qui a appareillé elle va devoir
compenser cette adaptation aux nappes de
en adoptant des stratégies qui vont être
spécifique pour s'en rendre compte en
fait il faut imaginer vous descendez un
escalier avec des chaussures de ski vous
avez une raideur qui est beaucoup trop
importante
le seul moyen de remplacer le mouvement
de votre cheville ça va être de mettre
le milieu de votre pied sur le nez de la
marche et de faire la bascule autour
sonnette marche
voilà à quoi ça ressemble une personne
qui a appareillé aujourd'hui elle va
être en permanence obligé de viser le
milieu de la marche le nez de la marche
avec le milieu de son pied pour
permettre à son tibia de passer au
dessus de cette marche alors dans le
monde il ya énormément de développement
et de travaux qui cherche à résoudre ces
problèmes
aujourd'hui vous avez des solutions ou
hydraulique on va chercher à mettre des
microprocesseurs à l'intérieur de ces
systèmes hydrauliques pour remplacer la
cheville est de même des systèmes
motorisés qui vont donc modifier la
position cette cheville et apporter de
l'énergie à l'utilisateur nous on a
plutôt cherché à partir sur un concept
un petit peu différent j'avais pris le
temps au tout début de vous parler des
muscles biais articulaires parce que les
deux les deux jumeaux donc qui constitue
notre mollet donc un des plus gros
muscles de notre jambes est un muscle
bien articulé c'est un muscle qui vient
s'insérer au dessus du genou
et qui vient s'insérer après la cheville
donc on est parti de ce principe là on a
dessiné sur une feuille de papier un
système vie articulaires avec une
articulation au genou une articulation à
la cheville et on a imaginé un
actionneur hydraulique reliant les deux
articulations connectés hydrauliquement
qui permet de transférer d'énergie entre
le genou et la cheville et après on a
des capteurs un microcontrôleur qui va
nous permettre de piloter la réponse
mécanique de ce dispositif
on a travaillé avec différents
laboratoires en europe
dans un premier temps pour équiper nos
premiers prototypes avec une multitude
de capteurs
donc ce n'était pas forcément très
séduisant au départ recueillir de
l'information et créer des premiers
algorithme qui nous permettait de nous
repérer dans notre cycle de marche
à partir de ces mêmes capteurs en les
interrogeant à des moments bien précis
de ce cycle de marche et ben en fait on
est en permanence en train d'essayer
d'estimer la situation dans laquelle la
personne se trouve qu'on a estimé cette
la situation dans laquelle on est encore
faut-il apporter la bonne adaptation au
bon moment donc grâce à un projet qui a
été financée par l' agence nationale de
la recherche n'a pu travailler avec
différents centres cliniques et pendant
ce projet sur les photos que vous avez à
gauche en fait on a fait marcher des
personnes asymptomatiques et des
personnes appareillées dans les
situations qu'elles rencontrent
quotidiennement peuvent leur apporter
des difficultés à marcher dans dépendant
des escaliers dans des dévers et ce
qu'on cherche c'est mesurer les
compensations qu'elles sont obligées de
mettre en place pour franchir ces et
voir comment nous on s'adapte
quelles sont les modifications
mécaniques que nous nous apportons et
sur la vidéo vous avez à droite c'est un
des prototypes où on essayait les
premières adaptations qu'on pouvait
mettre en place donc vous voyez la
personne qui monte un escalier qui
montrent une pente au fur et à mesure de
la pente
la position de sa cheville en fait va
s'adapter à l'évolution de 70 et en
descente d'escalier le mouvement de la
cheville qui est autorisé au final n'est
uniquement dû au fait que la personne
est en train d'utiliser son genou est le
genou savait qu'on est dans un escalier
du coup elle ne fait que passer cette
information à la cheville reproduit
l'action de ce muscle bj articulaires et
permet ce mouvement de réflexion de jeu
aller de plus en plus loin on est dans
un monde qui bouge extrêmement vite dans
ce système là il ya des composants
électroniques qui écoutait il ya 5 6 ans
dix fois cent fois le prix qui coûte
aujourd'hui et donc on sait que dans ce
monde en perpétuel évolution on va
pouvoir aller de plus en plus loin et
l'on souhaite nous c'est qu'on aille
dans la vie réelle et que ces
technologies servent à des personnes
dans leur quotidien voilà
[Applaudissements]